also ich zeige euch jetzt mal eine hose
weil ich habe mir die hose geht ist
wegen gta so ein bisschen heller
jetzt ist jetzt ein bisschen dunkel weil
der gta das bereitet mir natürlich schon
ein bisschen versteht
natürlich versteht dass jeder das hat
auch einfach jeder hey leute und
herzlich willkommen zu einer mega
projekt folge heute bei mir am abend
zumindest zusammen mit lp mit cathay
gestellt noch die sonne nie bei mir ist
bei mir scheint noch die sonne bei mir
ist gerade kurz vor 5 allerdings kommt
die folge bei mir am abend online weil
ich brauch wieder zwei stunden hochladen
und dann noch ändern und blablabla
deswegen auch wenn sie die wenn ihr
gatte folge sehen wenn sie gerade online
gekommen ist dann wunderschönen guten
abend durch guten abend ok ich schaue
mir mal ganz kurz wenn ich mit hitze an
die pickepackevoll alan simon schon mal
was das thema ist und zwar wollen wir
etwas über gta 5 reden
ich persönlich als absoluter fan und
extremer kanti konsolenspieler gegen den
luca der deckung so liebhaber ist und
ist so wir werden uns ein bisschen hier
betteln was so an konsole gutes was one
pc gut ist ich zocke auf beiden auf pc
mit nicht mehr so viel allerdings sehr
sehr viel ps3 einfach in letzter zeit
mit kumpels und so und wir werden halt
auch gta 5 unter die lupe nehmen dazu
wird dann hauptsächlich ich was sagen
kann allerdings hätte ich sagen was ich
bisher so gesehen habe in gta 5
weil ich jetzt schon vier stunden
spielzeit habe und dass er sich so
erhofft von der pc-version ich will das
mal sagen warum findest du pc eigentlich
besser kev also ich muss sowieso sagen
pc hatte ich immer das gefühl dass man
mehr möglichkeiten hatte so habe ich das
damals kennengelernt
als es dann beides gab beziehungen
konsole und konsole noch nicht so im
hype war klar hatte ich auch nintendo 64
und so aber irgendwie als damals hatte
hatte ich dann mehr möglichkeiten an
spielen ich hatte da alles ich hatte da
konnte konnte mit leuten chatten man
konnte zocken man konnte was dort muss
sie können pc war für alles und ich
hatte niemals deswegen so konsolen und
mir ist häufig aufgefallen dass die
grafik teilweise schlechter aber bei den
soll und man einfach zum beispiel jetzt
von der steuerung war das so ist so
shooter habe ich eigentlich immer gerne
gezeichnet so bevor ich dieses komische
drei hektar oder diesen knüppel in
richtung bewege beispielsweise command
conquer oder irgendwelchen shootern
so schnell kann man sich gar nicht
bewegen da bist einfach viel bessere
spieler wenn am pc ist ja das ist mir
bei shootern ist mir das auf jeden fall
auch aufgefallen und zwar bin ich ja
hättet mich zu tode ich mag cod
eigentlich und sollen so richtig shooter
spielen will mag ich auch wirklich cod
spiel dann auch liebend gern cod wenn
ich dann allerdings mal irgendwie so in
die welt gehen will und einfach mal so
ein bisschen so rum fahren will aber
trotzdem so mit schouten und ein shoot
schießen
da möchte er so der battlefield typ und
ich finde man kann zum beispiel auf
konsole und pc auf battlefield bezogen
sehr sehr gut fliegen oder auch autos
fahren allerdings finde ich dass man
schießen wirklich viel viel besser auf
dem pc machen kann
shooter gibt es die leute wenn man mit
pc angefahren hat mit shootern so wie
ich mit mw2 war es damals
da habe ich mit pc shooter mw2
angefangen da konnte ich das auf dem pc
relativ gut und dann bin ich auf konsole
gegangen und hab einfach so verpackt
weil ich einfach mit der steuerung nicht
da kam weiß geschäft du drückst den
rechten stick einmal nach rechts und du
drehst dich eine komplette runde und so
was alles was ist ein fohlen die ist
einfach also ich weiß nicht aber ich
finde es auf dem mauspad ist das auch
wissen ja du kannst nämlich einfach so
dein mauspad nehmen das einfach so jetzt
auch da ist eine anzugucken und so
stecken so zack zack zack
also das ist eigentlich relativ geil auf
pc muss mit schwenker under geben da
gebe ich sogar wer dir recht auf dem pc
allerdings werden hat freunde dazu wenn
man will dann zusammen auf irgendwelche
shooter spiel dann ist natürlich auch
der konsole wieder ganz geheilt
das wollte ich nämlich sagen das ist
nämlich der große vorteil an der konsole
und zwar also wie gesagt skype ezb
darüber vor dass kann man also ein
spezial mit freunden zocken aber konsole
hat halt eben zeige ich mal den
gesellschaftlichen faktor das heißt du
kannst da völlig entspannt mit deinen
freunden zocken die sind dann auch bei
dir zu hause oder dubai den und das
macht es halt irgendwie auch chilliger
finde ich denn freuen uns über diesen
gemacht so pcl und soja du spielst du
runde ich bin runde sitzt man zusammen
vom pc konsole ist einfach zu schließen
fernseher antritt sich auf verkauf
spiel zusammen die fifa dagegen in runde
vier rennen fahren an gta einfach mal so
abwechseln so was alles das natürlich an
dieser chillige gesellschaftliche
vorteile das ist richtig cool dass das
hat natürlich an der sache besser
allerdings jetzt mal auf nicht nur
konsolen krieg mäßig bezogen sondern mal
auf speziell gta bezogen kannst du jetzt
zwar relativ wenig sagen
allerdings haben wir sehr viele leute da
ich bei facebook gepostet habe ihr seht
mich in der woche wieder unser ganzen
scheiß haben sehr sehr viele jahr locker
macht doch mal hier
geht er als player oder sagt und
zumindest mal deine meinung zu gta habe
ich mir das gedacht
der kef hat er abgeschrieben hat
irgendwer zeit zum aufnehmen da hab ich
mir gedacht da kommen richtig zusammen
darüber reden über die weiß bescheid was
hinten ich mich verstört schon die erste
frage die ich aber habe wie lange kennst
du schon geht er an sich bei salamis
aller ersten gta was rausgekommen ist
mit gt r 1 wo man noch 2d grafik von
oben hatte da hab ich schon angefangen
das damals zu zocken und zwar auf dem
computer meines opas und seitdem habe
ich jeden tag beim rallye fantastic
heraus keine ahnung dabei sechs oder für
die albis jetzt 23 das heißt wer dann
bin ich dann wäre ich da glatt geboren
ich dass ich gespielt noch ganz genau
wenn man seinen namen asset management
hat man alle waffen untersucht habe
verschiedene wär ja das ist wirklich
sind und so hat es angefangen der zweite
war dann so dass man längst machen
konnte und der dritte teil oder
vielleicht versuche ich jetzt meinen
teil 2 war dann schon wieder mehr diese
3d sich zur halb verließen und ab dem
vierten bleibt uns dann andreas das war
dann so richtig 3d grafisch auch
trotziger und jetzt kommt's 55 war also
bei mir was erstmalig haben andreas
angefangen die davor da habe ich die
reihe in die nie richtig bemerkt weil
den durchbruch hat einen durchbruch
durchbruch hatten somit sei es die san
andreas mit den teilen so bei bei sehr
vielen spielen so dass sie mit
bestimmten teilen sondern so einen
gewissen durchbruch feiern
die sache ist auch allerdings dass sich
zahl andreas immer nur so bei kumpels
gespielt habe da meine eltern sich immer
so gegen eine konsole gesträubt haben
und ich dann immer neue konsole zu
bekommen hatte ich muss ganz kurzen
schild bei denen ersetzen der hat hier
nicht geantwortet einfach der dass
einfach der luft gesprengt mit simon
dachte wir wollten
wir wollten chat marken traurigen smiley
ja ich komm vorbei bringt karotten mit
nicht so viel gespielt allerdings hat es
nicht schon damals so viel spaß gemacht
weil das einfach so das erste open world
spiel was ich überhaupt entdeckt dazu
wochen machen was man will und dann ich
weiß dass sein andreas kommt man sich
immerhin seien allerdings reinlegen in
sonne habe ich gar nicht mit nicht
reichen
ja da kommen wir zum schwitzen kommt vom
meer werden
ja man kann sich in welche häuser
einlegen
so warten dass polizei kommt dann alle
abknallen ist alles so typisch gta hält
damals sowieso einfach autos klauen so
rum fahren und diese geile welt und
diese straße da wo man wohnt was als boa
megageil im land hat sich jeder
gewünscht dass diese wohnen wie die
leute an der straße und auch dass
andreas war so alle meinten so war es
andreas beste spieler und so gta 4 fand
ich jetzt nicht so geil von der story
her und so was alles dazu auch cool so
new york war mal was anderes so aber ich
finde mit gta 5 to back to the roots
zurück zu den wurzeln
man ist ja in lausanne tas das ist
glaube ich sogar in san andreas
wenn ich das nicht ganz an die reihe
ich dachte schon so warum stimmt nicht
zu alter von gta 4 habe ich nicht so
viel gesuchte allerdings immer mal so er
online somit partner also mit felix
unter anderem also den damals sofort
vereinen anderthalb jahren damit dass da
schon gespielt und das war halt immer so
ein bisschen schäbig allerdings von der
story her fand ich nie so geil und dann
was halt letztendlich so dass halt jetzt
geht ja fünf rausgekommen ist wenn ihr
das video seht habe ich mir gestern
gekauft
ich wurde übrigens im supermarkt erkannt
wo ich mir das gekommen zwei dieser
hague am crafter ich will die jungs
etwas machst du ja ich höre wie es geht
ja gekauft
april 20 besten schon bestellt für
bettwäsche und das spiel gegen artikel
und trinken und alles wirklich was wir
so brauchten gestern oder gestern ich
habe das noch niemals erlebt in hannover
wohnen wird sich die heute nur ich war
einkaufen bei planung kurz zu bank was
ist was
business und so und ich gehe aber nur
zur bahn
hey alter kerl der trend kräftig der
rassist käfer der rest ist aber ist
schwarz war das nicht sein muss man
manchmal das schwarze schon richtig aber
in dem zusammenhang so und der war
schwarz jetzt ein des todes 1 starten
ja das habe ich auch gedacht deswegen
will ich ganz schnell ablenken
wie mache ich noch mal col du hast hast
du genau was ich in wales raceway den
mainframe richtig mit einem so warten
noch ganz kurz zu gta und zwar dann habe
ich mir das geld gekauft habt dann
konnte ich konnte nicht spielen
ich fahre nach hause mit meiner mama
weil dies mit gekommen weil wir muss
doch woanders her du bist du dick bist
shopping tour gemacht plan und zu jucken
das unter anderem auch jedenfalls nicht
nein ich werde in drei monaten
die polizei ist oder sich über die jahre
darauf gewartet dann ich konnte nicht
spielen weil meine mama meinte so also
ich habe meiner mutter gesagt ja ich
muss noch trainieren gehen pope
blablabla
nein du gehst jetzt nach hause und
spielt ein spiel das hat sie mir gesagt
sobald ich war doch ein bisschen
kränklich da wäre es ihm lieber gewesen
ich zu hause dieses spiel gesagt ja dann
statt zum training gehen ich liebe deine
mama war läuft bei dir auf jeden fall
aber ich muss jetzt bin ich so zum
training dann hatte ich einen platten
ich war erstmal zwei stunden trainieren
dann hatte ich einen platten dann war
ich erst um halb elf zu hause gegessen
hausaufgaben gemacht dass ihnen
gestaltet
oft kommen die pendler mit noch ein
bisschen wollte das junge und dann hör
mir zu am nächsten tag also heute ich
hatte heute erste zweite und fünfte
sechste stunde perfekter tag dann hätte
ich in den freistunden zocken können
dabei zwei freistunden hat ihn nach
hause und gar nicht gezockt hab ne ich
hab noch nicht gezockt habt und nach der
sechsten hätte ich zocken konvent nach
der sechsten hatte ich dann halt
komplett frei heute deswegen demokrat
mit ihr auf also seid ein erstes signal
wahrheit verstehen vorn und finden nicht
gestern nach dem studio
ja da hast du zu hause und da gehörte
tatsächlich weist machen dass du dich
einfach schlafen
ich war super ohne wenn man denn nun
platten hat einfach mal die ganzen
kilometer dann nach hause schieben
mussten so was alles an zu hause bis
hausaufgaben machen musst du bist
einfach des des todes karäter ganz
opfers sein können
mit einem auge einem bein ich hätte das
spiel trotzdem wenigstens schon mal
reingeschoben ist ja reingeschoben hab
ich's ja ich hab's ja installieren
lassen und so was alles ich war auch
schon kurz drin ich hab mich so ins
rollen kommt aber ich hab's noch nie so
richtig noch nicht so richtig gespielt
zu bis zu ersten also hast sagt einmal
klar dass natürlich natürlich ist das
wäre ich doch nicht kommt gibt sich auch
keine schuss bevor ich schlafen geht
sozusagen das war beim bürger vergleich
jetzt auf mich dazu als lukas chyla
davon wissen wer sich so zurück zum
thema jedenfalls ich konnte heute immer
noch nicht spielen heute in den zwei
freistunden weil ich fahre nach hause
mit dem ersatz parat die kette geht
einfach ab ich mit irgendwann schwarzen
hände kommt nach hause
auch wieder so geschoben ich hab's ja
nicht an gekriegt weil das bei seinem
mountainbike hätte dies übel schwer dran
zu kriegen was schon die hände fünf
minuten dann musste ich mein fahrrad was
einen platten hatte vom vortag musste
dann zum fahrrad doktor bringen alles
möglich muss ich machen dann direkt
wieder zur schule dann nach der schule
ich komme nach hause musste ich im brief
an der uni schreiben jetzt gerade um 14
uhr konnte die erste mal zocken und
jetzt nämlich 14 uhr 3
ja dies komplett nass deswegen wenn man
nicht jeder zeit ist kein unterschied
die zeit nur dann ein bisschen dunkler
und ein bisschen strammer jetzt also ich
zeig euch jetzt mal eine hose weil ich
habe mir die hose geht ist wegen gta
da dies dies komplett nass vorher war
die man so ein bisschen heller
jetzt ist so ein bisschen dunkel weil
der gta das bereitet mir natürlich schon
so ein bisschen
am anfang steht natürlich versteht dass
jeder das hat auch einfach jeder sagen
damit wissen wir wie du zum zocken kommt
ich habe immer nur eine frage und ich
hab das ja auch schon so erzählt ich
verstehe es nicht und ob das wirklich so
ist ich bezweifle dass irgendwie so
kommen alle geilen spiele für konsolen
raus und für pc nicht das hast du das ja
vorhin schon bemängelt als vielleicht
vergleichen kommentare stein war ich
meine ob man jetzt konsole oder pc
spielt das sollte dem user überlassen
sein sage ich mal
aber jetzt bin ich ich bin ja gezwungen
mir jetzt im laufe dieser woche also das
hat über den playstation 3 oder warte
ich auf die playstation 4 gucke
playstation 4 release 2 monate nein
kannst du nicht warten
das heißt ich bin jetzt wirklich gibt es
funkt wie alle kameras zu kaufen die ihm
eine playstation monitor oder sogar so
ein game capture grad ach so was gibt s
ja klar
damit hast du ja wie gesagt da muss mir
sowas kaufen a 12 50 zoll flatscreen der
passt ich keine wand fahre habe ich
könnte mir eine polizistin aber warum
gar kein tages nicht mehr rein und ja da
muss man das spiel kaufen
wie also wenn du das ist bei mir das
problem mit fifa 14 und einfach gta 5
weil im november kommt die dings ich
beantworte diese frage welchen und
erstmal ein problem hier ja genau könnt
ihr einfach schreibt zwar in die
kommentare erst mal was sie für eine
konsole habt schreibt alle eure konsolen
mal witzigen kommentare und was ihr
denkt warum die das einfach zu früh raus
bringen schreibt das war jetzt rein weil
gleich versuche ich meine bedeutung ich
ein bisschen zu bringen
und was war also ich habe es einen tag
vorm release bekommen htc kommt ja erst
in diesem herbst komplettes ich meine
die konsolenversionen vor dem pc version
rauskommt was denkt ihr woran das liegt
so sagt nicht irgendwie vom coding her
oder so oder kann könnt ihr endlich auch
schreiben eigentlich auch ein argument
naja jedenfalls bei mir ist es zurzeit
so ich habe jetzt gta 5 und in der woche
hole ich mir auf jeden fall auch fifa 14
mal sind die zwei letzten spiele finde
ich wo ich am längsten run spaß haben
werde
und ich hab mich jetzt halt beide für
ps3 geholt
beide für ps3 also geht die arbeit auf
ihr spiel ja das beantworten
also ich vor allem ich wollte sagen kann
man hier auch ps3 vier spielen weil wir
ja sowieso eingebracht
ich habe jetzt jedenfalls fifa 14 werde
ich mir dann auf ps3 kaufen
dann habe ich die beiden für ps3 die
sache ist dann halt die das in zwei
monaten genau wenn fifa 14 rauskommt
genau zwei monaten kommt die ps4 raus
deswegen die sache ist die ich habe die
ganzen spiele dann für ps3 und dann
werde ich sie mir noch mal für ps4
kaufen müssen bei fifa die haben sollen
trading pack gemacht dass wenn man das
für ps3 schon gekauft hat dass man das
andere dann zum halben preis bekommt
also gta das aber denkt allerdings nicht
das heißt das muss ich einfach nochmal
kaufen ich weiß nicht ob man drei spiele
auf vier spielen kann
das weiß nicht das habe ich noch nicht
durchgelesen haben ja auch glaube ich
auch nicht gesagt aber ich glaube ist
soll eventuell sogar funktionieren
allerdings ist immer noch ein bisschen
doof wenn es nicht funktioniert dann
muss ich mir die spiele wirklich normal
kaufen behindert das heißt wenn ich mir
jetzt das ganze equipment kaufen kann
ich praktisch schon sagen dass ich mir
zwei monaten das ganze kommt nochmal
kaufen weil eine ps4 kann man ja videos
aufnehmen und direkt auf youtube
hochladen
hp ist viel möglich beispielsweise das
ist allerdings auf zum beispiel möglich
bei elgato game capture card womit du
deinen links aufnimmst elgato game
capture card bringt nur ein bild von der
playstation offen dingsda aber mit
meinen kommentar ihm eine face kjaer
muss er deswegen deswegen theoretisch
könntest du aber gameplays direkt von
der elgato karte hoch nach so und bei
einer ps4 soll aber alles mögliche gehen
hab ich zumindest so gehört wehrt kann
sein
sicher hat die man ganz kassierte paar
sachen den legen rief ein album brauche
ich mag das dach der moment eher
batterie was habe ich davon nicht noch
übels viele audio ich hab noch zwölf
alter ist das ist so geil immer wenn ich
so sehe ich habe letztens schon
vorproduzierte mit der batterien
wirklich diese 3d also ich habe einfach
so immer mehr gemacht immer so
nee also immer wenn ich hab mir so
gedacht sogar kommen jetzt hast du je
batterie das rezept gerade drin liegen
die ganzen ressourcen da machst du dir
anstatt einer die du jetzt gerade
braucht halt einfach mal dann zehn dann
brauste später keine mehr weil die
braucht man immer und immer wieder in
kings jedenfalls ist halt meine sache
jetzt ein bisschen wie soll ich das
alles regel mit den ganzen konsolen
sachen ich werde dann wahrscheinlich als
normal kaufen müssen
also das wird wahrscheinlich nicht
anders irgendwie gehen design ist der
welt unfair gemacht da sagt man das ist
das eigentlich würde ich sogar sagen
dass es nur geld kann ich meine das ist
die gleiche firma sie verdienen ihr geld
und wieso dann den user ausziehen
bis auf die knochen ja also es ist auch
sehr oft also was mir auch aufgefallen
ist ist das zum beispiel xbox xbox
kennst du richtig ja ja logisch muss man
ihren pc spieler mal gefragt ob es aus
die konsumwelt
es gibt ja von playstation einmal das
dass man dieses move ja dann gab es auch
vor von xbox oder war das xbox das davor
das war
xbox kinect er genau kinect war das und
das hatte mein bester kumpel auf das
haben wir auch richtig viel gezockt
solche so was street fighter so ähnlich
dass wie langer zeit musste aber es
selber uns bewegen sollte so schlägerei
aber auch virtuell so mäßig na ja genau
naja kann ich halt übels kleine aber
sehr wandel aber ich hab selber keine
konsole fifa habe ich auch gespielt pro
evolution soccer ich hab doch eine
meinung welche sich von beiden besser
finde und so und das interessiert dich
jetzt ja was denn als rede jetzt besser
weil du kein ich kann dir sagen dass die
pest besser findest du kein fußball fan
bist du nicht auf lizenzen achtes und
das gameplay mehr bevorzugst ich muss
sowieso sagen fußball ist so abgemalt
schwierig auf der konsole junge ist
megageil es ist schwierig sagt schweer
was ihr schwierig das ist federleicht
megageil mega leicht wenn das ding ist
ich bin ein nichtspieler meine besten
freunde spielen das immer egal was gegen
die fußballspiele dann wirklich einfach
nur so wtf 10 0 und das in zwei minuten
halbzeiten oder so ich mache alles
richtig
offenbar nicht anscheinend nicht ich bin
kein fußballfan deswegen wahrscheinlich
ist das aber nicht meint ja manche leute
haben ja eventuell vorteile indem ein
spiel aber dafür nach thailänder anderen
spielen wo wohlstand jetzt reden ach ja
xbox hat zb vertrag mit den fifa
herstellern weil die besonders bei fifa
jetzt kann man das sehr gut machen weil
alle leute die sich xbox also die sich
fifa für die xbox one heißt er glaube
ich richtig ja alle die sich xbox fifa
für eine xbox man kaufen die kriegen
seien extra pack dazu die kriegen so
extra packs an spielern und so was alles
also deswegen weil halt xbox weiß halt
dass sie mit der xbox wann den totalen
rein sturz landen werden wahrscheinlich
auch schon
jedenfalls haben die haben sich als ein
totales eigentor geschossen
und deswegen dachten wir zu jahr da
gehen jetzt mal auf die user dann gehen
wir mal auf die hälfte auf die
hersteller zu anstatt auf die user bei
den usern armenischen vergangen alle die
einfach bei fifa jetzt so ein bisschen
allerdings machen wollen bis sie mit
salz da spielen wollen die müssen sich
jetzt eine extra version für xbox
wandhofen alle playstation spieler
bekommen dies nicht so das ist erstmal
richtig als sie von xbox gewesen aber
wenn man genug kohle hat dann ist es
natürlich alles möglich aber anlass für
die youtube anif offene und dann auf gar
keinen fall kaufen ja es ist natürlich
blöd dieses gewisse ja kommen
wir haben asche bild machen jetzt
einfach so als wenn hier wir geben euch
zehn millionen dafür dass ihr das nur
für unsere konsole entwickelt so nach
dem motto das ist einfach nur scheiße
was gehört sich auch nicht ich meine man
sollte wenn man konsolen macht das ist
muss für die user ein klares man
irgendwo wirtschaftlich denken was uns
für das alles ja nicht bestehen aber ich
denke wirtschaftlich wirtschaftlich
gesehen geht es ja noch klar was sie
machen aber um nochmal jetzt hier das
ganze thema abzuschließen gta ist für
mich einfach mal das geilste spiel
mittlerweile ihr habt man sich gar nicht
immer geht ja gesagt ja deswegen weil
ich das immer ganz kurz sagen und zwar
ist es einfach mega geil weil man
einfach überall rum fahren kann es gibt
so viele vorteile das habe ich kann auch
schon gesagt ich bin einfach mal am
strand her gefahren und ich sehe einfach
mal sowie dings wieso 200 [ __ ] wie so
ein typ da am pump willst weil ich war
klar dass vögel sagt dass edward das
wollte was ist monaten noch zensiert
werden müssen
[ __ ] [ __ ] einbiegen und haben
versprochen bieten was sie anbieten
gesagt oder habe ich doch oder her klar
was auch sonst
weil die leuten vertraut sind die halt
das was wir wollen ist so also sich
gegenseitig komme zu dir kommt den bis
hin zu der kunst ein ganz klein bisschen
youtuber der spiele ich wenig bauland
allerdings es gibt ja drei charaktere
ich habe bisher erst zwei kennengelernt
oder doch 3
waren das auf jeden fall franklin
michael und entweder lama oder lässt da
ich weiß nicht wer dritter war schreibt
die kommentare wenn der dritte weil wenn
ich schon gespielt hat ich bin gerade
mit mike nehmen mit franklin habe ich
war ich habe auch franklin gewechselt
weil ich habe alles mit michael gemacht
bei michael bin ich gerade dabei das ich
aktien wo aktiengeschäfte kennenlerne
und bei was denn diese sterbe ich da
drauf auf dieser platte hieß verwackeln
und spricht übels falsch an
ich habe ein herz und zwar mit michael
habe ich bin ich gerade dabei wurde
daran diese aktien sachen run geführt
wird also der hat ja gerade diesen typen
umgebracht er da dieses dieses handy
hatte und dann hab ich mal gedacht
sojakomplex frank denn ich habe so viel
mit michael diesem reichen familien
schnöde da gesagt bei dem die familie
komplett im arsch ist manchmal gedacht
zu jahr kommen mache ich ein bisschen
was mit franklin und bei franklin war es
so dass ich gerade jetzt bei der
recycling mission ist wo er einen
aufsatz für die stadt land kaufen muss
und dann zu dem recyclinghof fahren muss
also das war jetzt kann so richtiger
spoiler ist hat jetzt auch keiner
verstanden ohne kakadu glaubst kann wie
sehr ich mich auf das spiel gefreut
haben und dann mussten wir planen das pc
version später das kommt ja so
jedenfalls es ist einfach richtig geil
vor allem diese ganzen details die
gemacht wurden das ist so hammer
übrigens hier gerade cavs megageil
parcours jump von erding ist ich hatte
keinen jetpack und ich habe auch keine
energiequelle zum aufladen
das so gemacht wenn ich auf land will
dass sie mich einfach hier zum haus
katapultieren kann ich veröffentliche
plate nutzen wenn ich dann zurück will
dann gehe ich einfach ihr oder von simon
die das ja auch schon durch den putsch
von simon durch den wurf von sehen man
ja also warum es geht ja fünf so geil
megageil details ich verstand ich sie
vögeln bieten die hunde
ich sehe man sieht auch
links hier so einfach mal so leute die
einfach mal pumpen da am strand und so
was alles also das ist einfach nur zu
hammergeil oder auch diese ganzen
aufträge man kann wirklich fast überall
rein gehen in alle häuser ohne zu laden
und man kann zwischen charakteren
wechseln und die geilen autos und ich
stehe wirklich so oben im hollywood
studio bei den hollywood beverly hills
studios dabei den ganzen willen in einem
corvette da und genießt einfach den
sonnenuntergang geht danach eine runde
joggen eine runde tauchen und sowas als
das ist megageil einfach werden und zwar
für alle altersgruppen
ok schießen uns jetzt weiß nicht
allerdings ist ist so geil einfach nur
zwischen mega geil und ich kann es
wirklich alle neuen vielen kauft euch
das spiel unterstützt rockstar die sind
hammer geil und ich liebe dich einfach
bei denen einfach die machen auch wenn
gta4 so ein bisschen doof
es war trotzdem kein totaler reinfall
wie irgendwie mw2 oder mp3 oder so also
die sind echt coole entwickler mag ich
sehr
und ich liebe dieses spiel einfach nicht
freue mich dass ich jedoch einfach
wieder spielen kann ist mir natürlich
leid dass ich bin wirklich zu überlegen
soll ich mir jetzt wirklich eine konsole
holen und ich war nie klar sagt
playstation holen aber weil es ist ja
bei twitter in zukunft bei allen spielen
so sein dass sie erst auf playstation
rauskommt und seien wir mal ehrlich
jeder normale mensch hat eine konsole
außer ich ja däne hatte bis vor kurzem
auch keine doch der hätte man der xbox
aber mit seinem bruder und seiner
schwester geteilt der ehrliche meinung
lohnt ist sich jetzt eine playstation 3
zu kommen
außer du bist übels verrückt nach dem
spiel und das bist du ja ich weiß nicht
ich muss ja auch immer meine belichtung
verstellbar face cam weil einfach das
ist einfach die hände hat er verändert
sich alles
die kommentare vielleicht könnt ihr mir
da weiterhelfen lohnt sich jetzt noch
eine playstation 3 zu holen bleibt bei
mir rein ob sich das für clown teilt
auch ob ihre konsole hat oder ob wir
schon gta habe das interessiert mich
echt oder wo ihr geradezu vom später
spielt er nicht so schreibe ja ich bin
dort wo die frau von franklin gestorben
ist oder so keine ahnung hast du nicht
sondern setzte schreibt ihnen sagen was
schön dass ihr dabei weiterhin ich
musste schnell nach hause fahren laufen
ja mach schon mal beendet und dann würde
ich etwas sagen schön dass ihr dabei
wenn es euch gefallen hat und dir geht
hier auf gelb findet deutlich nach oben
bei beiden videos und ansonsten wünscht
sich natürlich noch einen schönen abend
bleibt geilo mach's gut bis ein cha cha
er kommt auf einmal jedes video guckt
hab euch ganz stolz kauft euch alle gta
5 und schreibt dass die sachen wie wir
gesagt haben die kommentare
ich will dich mal gesponsert von denen
ich hab noch nie geredet aber trotzdem
das spiel ist einfach nur geil und ihr
werdet es nicht bereuen
bei mir ist auch egal